the stimulus bill that was just
unleashed this 1.9 trillion dollar
monstrosity that was just unleashed
by the federal government is a radical
shift in the nature
of the relationship between the
government and the individual
it involves a massive bailout to all of
the states and localities that have done
a horrible job
running their own business it has also
created essentially a brand new welfare
program
okay the welfare program rolls back
welfare reform welfare reform in the
1990s was designed to get people off the
welfare rules and encourage people to
work
and there's a lot of talk at the time
well this is going to create child
poverty it didn't create child poverty
all it did was push people back to work
well the new plan
from joe biden this stimulus bill
essentially creates a
a baseline universal basic income for
people
with kids now it is not connected to
work it is not connected to unemployment
it is not connected to anything it's a
new entitlement
okay and the way that you can tell it to
entitlement is the way the media are
talking about it's supposed to sunset
next year
but republicans are then going to be in
the position of saying okay it needs to
go away
and democrats know this which is why
they passed it in the first place
the new york times calls it a policy
revolution in aid for children
according to jason deparle a year ago
anik hope a single mother in suburban
atlanta was working as a letter carrier
running a side business catering picnics
and settling into a rent to own home in
stone mountain georgia where she thought
her boys would flourish in class and
excel on the football field
then the pandemic closed the schools the
boy's grades collapsed with distance
learning should quit work to stay home
in hopes of breaking their fall
unexpected unemployment aid expecting
unemployment that never came she lost
her utilities ran short on food was
recovering from an immobilizing bout of
covet when a knock brought marshalls
with eviction papers
depending on when the snapshot is stated
miss hope might appear as a striving
emblem of upward morbidity or a mother
on the verge of homelessness but in
either guys she's among the people
democrats seek to help
with a mold-breaking plan on the verge
of congressional passage to provide most
parents a monthly check
of up to 300 per child obscured by other
parts of president biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus package
the child benefit has the makings of a
policy revolution see this is the thing
there's a lot in there
okay it is not just that people who are
unemployed get checks
that would make some sense right if
you're talking about the government
forcing people into unemployment lines
then the government compensating them
for forcing them into unemployment lines
makes some sense that is a taking when
the government takes your job the
government has to compensate you for the
taking of your job
okay but what we are talking about now
is setting up what is effectively a
permanent
welfare program though framed in
technocratic terms as an expansion
of as an expansion of an existing tax
credit it's essentially a guaranteed
income for families with kids akin to
children's allowances that are common
in other rich countries it's just like
europe so that means it's good
the basic idea here is that the child
tax credit which used to be applied
against the taxes you paid right that's
why it's called a tax credit
if you didn't pay taxes you didn't get
the child tax credit well now it doesn't
matter whether you pay taxes you still
get what we're going to lie about and
call a tax credit it's not a tax credit
because you're not paying taxes
it's just a redistribution check the
plan establishes the benefit for a
single year but if it becomes permanent
says the new york times as democrats
intend it will greatly enlarge the
safety net for the poor and the middle
class
at a time when the volatile modern
economy often leaves families moving
between those groups
more than 93 percent of children 69
million would receive benefits under the
plan at a one-year cost of more than 100
billion dollars
it raises the maximum benefit most
families will receive by up to 80 per
child extends it to millions of families
whose earnings
are currently too low to qualify under
existing law because again it was a
child tax credit so they're just
backdooring
right they're saying this is not a ch
it's not a child tax credit anymore now
it is a check
now one of the things that the
government did in the 1960s is they
dramatically increased the single
motherhood rate
in both the black and the white
communities in the in in
1960 the black single motherhood rate
was 20 today it's in excess of 70
in the white community the white single
motherhood rate was somewhere on the
order of five percent today it's in
excess of 40
that is specifically because of welfare
policies that incentivize people to have
kids and not have a husband in the home
because if the income got too high you
didn't get that you didn't get the
credit from the welfare program
this is not quite that but the
similarities are pretty stunning
while the current program distributes
money annually as a tax reduction
to families with income tax liability or
a check to those two poor to oh income
taxes the new program would set both
groups monthly checks
to provide a more stable cash flow by
the standards of previous day's debate
of previous aid debates opposition has
been surprisingly muted the bill hasn't
won any republican
votes but critics have focused on other
elements of the rescue package some
conservatives call the child benefit
welfare and warn that it's gonna bust
budgets and weaken incentives to work
or to marry which of course is correct
when the government becomes
apparent and essentially is footing all
your bills then your incentive to
actually create an upwardly mobile
family unit is greatly lessened
we you see less income mobility less
family formation less
productive i would say less productive
trajectory for children
in a situation in which the government
plays father it's a problem
okay but democrats are pushing that
forward so it's a reversion back to 1960
standards
of how the war on poverty was to be
fought by the way we have now spent 22
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
over the course of the war on poverty
and we have not budged the percentage of
people who are living below the poverty
line in the united states
pretty much at all the economic shock
and racial protest of the past year
brought new momentum
to the plans as the new york times whose
reach while broad would especially help
black and latino families
are crucial to the democrats coalition
okay so in other words it's a
specialized giveaway to a particular
voting block that biden wants to help
out
mr biden's embrace of the subsidies is a
leftward shift for a democratic party
that made deep cuts in cachet in the 90s
under the theme of ending welfare as a
senator biden supported the 1996 welfare
restrictions
as recently as august his campaign was
non-committal about the child benefit
now
the president promotes projections that
the monthly checks up to 300 bucks for
young children and 250 bucks for those
over five would cut poverty by 45
for children and by more than 50 among
black families
okay so here's the question is that true
because we've had these sorts of
benefits before it has not cut poverty
it turns out that you can sign checks to
these families and that doesn't mean
that poverty is going to be cut
in the end because in order to get out
of poverty you actually have to make a
series of decisions that get you out of
poverty over time
it is not merely a question of signing
people checks if it were merely a
question of signing people checks again
22 trillion dollars spent
over the last 60 years in the united
states would have been a pretty good way
to alleviate poverty it has not
alleviated poverty
in the united states in fact the black
middle class was growing faster in the
1950s than it has
after that thanks largely to the
intervention of the federal government
in welfare programs like this but again
this is the kind of policy that joe
biden is now pushing
or at least his administration is while
he's asleep on the couch
or at the denny's for the early bird
dinner
so that that is a major policy shift for
biden and of course he's going to be
championing that tonight he's going to
deliver a prime time address
on thursday actually marking the first
anniversary of the virus
restrictions and he's going to champion
his own role in overcoming
the virus now here's the thing his own
role in overcoming the virus has been
pretty limited
and you want an indicator of just what
joe biden has done on a personal level
there are supposed to be a hundred mass
vaccination sites set up by the federal
government by the end of february by the
end of february there were seven
these systems were in place it is
governors who have been doing the heavy
lifting here
all the federal government could do was
help actually obtain the vaccines
and the dosages any federal government
worth at salt would have done
all of that but you're going to see a a
victory lap here
by joe biden and again this is a heady
time because we're spending all the
money
and that's fine we're going to spend all
the money and it's gonna be all be great
because we're gonna spend all the money
we did this in the 60s
okay in the 1960s we blew out the
spending if you look at the growth rates
in the early 60s and gdp and the
american economy very very high
that was because the rest of the world
had been devastated by world war ii they
were still trying to
move beyond their own socialistic
policies many many of them had to curb
them those policies
in the 1960s the united states decided
it was going to become a social
democratic country
it's going to become much more european
in its view of the welfare state
we blew out the domestic spending we
actually blew out military spending as
well for a period there
and we ended up with the stagnation of
the 1970s an awful time for economics so
bad that there was a backlash in the
form of the reagan revolution in the
1980s
so that is what we are about to relive
we're basically just reliving
the mid-1960s to late 1970s
and this began over the course of the
past couple of years
with the with the pandemic it began with
the with the
racial protests and riots in america's
major cities it feels
very much like about 1968 right now it
feels a lot like that
in terms of where we are and what the
next decade is going to look like
and of course joe biden is in on it
meaning he's loving this stuff
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast
in the nation be sure to hit the
subscribe button to stay up to date on
all of our content